cities in the United States are seeking
advice from abroad to help fight climate
change the mayors of Boston and
Cambridge Massachusetts signed a pact
last month with a city of Copenhagen in
Denmark the goal is to share ideas to
create more sustainable cities
Copenhagen is considered a global leader
when it comes to clean energy the Danish
capital has transformed its
infrastructure with a goal to become the
first carbon-neutral city in the world
CBS's Sunday mornings Mo Rocca is at one
school in Copenhagen which serves as an
example of the city's dedication to the
cause mo good morning good morning I'm
out front of the solar powered
Copenhagen International School it's
just the latest architectural marvel to
grace this beautiful city and it's all
part of Copenhagen's ambitious plan to
become the cleanest energy city in the
world
Danish architecture has long been
renowned the world over for iconic
buildings like the Sydney Opera House
and LeGrande Arch in Paris for the kids
that can stand in look at the actual
panel and see oh this is how it works
but today's Danish architects like Matz
man drop are designing with a higher
purpose he was the lead architect
of the Copenhagen International School
essentially a solar power plant it is a
solar power plan we have about 12,000
square meters of solar panel see the
blue glass panels which vary in hue
depending on exposure to light provide
half of the building's power Denmark is
beautiful but it's not the sunniest
place in the world what happens on a
cloudy day on a cloudy day here produces
less but however we've been monitoring
and we aren't track in terms of the
numbers we set up of course
and Copenhagen is on track to reach its
goal of becoming the first
carbon-neutral city in the world
producing as much energy all of it clean
as it consumes by the year 2025 we are
currently investing just around a
billion dollars in wind turbines in and
around Copenhagen and in the future we
will be doing two you thermical heat and
of course we planned a whole lot of
trees Morten Cabal is Copenhagen's mayor
of technical and environmental affairs I
ride my bike every day I've never owned
a car and for many tourists and many
visitors coming to Copenhagen it's quite
a surprise to notice that bikes have
right-of-way in most of the city today
62 percent of commuters here biked to
work a movement that began during the
energy crisis of the 1970s gasoline is
so expensive that we had all these rules
that emphasize cycling architecture
Camilla Richter's freeze vendors says
creating a cleaner City has helped
create more people we're growing by
about a thousand people every month
people having more kids are having more
babies they're staying in the city
because the city is so livable her firm
Gehl architects help make New York's
Times Square pedestrian friendly and
designed a danish style network of bike
lanes throughout the city tell me why
our bicycle helmets not required they
did a study looking at the overall
health of people cycling in the city and
found that women are less likely to
cycle if you have to wear a helmet so
the health improves overall by not
making the helmets mandatory it
discouraging the use of cars has had
some unintended consequences the tax on
a car here can be as much as a hundred
and fifty percent of the sale price of
the actual car yes but one of the side
effects is that our collective current
mass is older and of course older cars
submit more co2 so it's not really doing
the best a minor speed bump perhaps on
Copenhagen's ride into a future best on
display in its ørestad neighborhood I
think what we've tried to do is to
infuse into this sort of contemporary or
modern form of architecture an element
that is like socially and
environmentally active björk Engels has
moved mountains into Copenhagen's
famously flat landscape this residential
tower has a grass rooftop and bike
trails that lead all the way to the top
and coming soon Denmark's first alpine
ski run built atop a power plant and yes
the plant itself is carbon neutral green
technology is not only good for the for
the bird so the fish it's amazing for
the citizens because now probably the
coolest Park in Copenhagen is going to
be the roof of our power plant Engels
says that steam you see is as clean as
mountain air ordains raised with a
consciousness about the climate and
about a healthy environment or I don't
think Danes are born with that but we
have a culture where we like to be
practical Danes love being lazy we are
as lazy as anybody else so it's about
making the right choice it's so that you
can be lazy well into the future
accept it and I must admit that there
are five year olds who go to this school
who know more about energy than I do and
coming up tomorrow I'm gonna give you
all a tour of the beautiful and historic
city of Copenhagen Gale you are not
gonna want to miss this I never want to
miss anything you do Mo Rocca
I've never been to Copenhagen you guys
have been I've been
I can't wait to see you soon he's also
doing a great piece about a fabulous
restaurant or yeah like we like Morocco
a lot but it seems like the US could
learn some things from Copenhagen I
don't think he was joking but the five
girls knowing more than we do yeah